[Música]
qué sabemos de florida conocido como el
estado del sol o el estado soleado
florida hace honor a su nombre el estado
limita con el golfo de méjico y disfruta
de un clima semitropical
sitios emblemáticos de florida manglares
y pantanos incluidos los everglades un
sitio declarado como patrimonio mundial
por la unesco es el tercer estado más
poblado del país con 21,48 millones de
habitantes la mayoría concentrados en
las costas capital del estado está lajas
y en el norte florida tiene el mayor
número de jubilados en eeuu en relación
con su población 20 9% también hay
fuertes comunidades latinas y cubanas el
turismo es la principal fuente de
ingreso del estado las playas y los
parques temáticos aportan miles de
millones de dólares al producto interno
bruto de florida cada año con 29 votos
del colegio electoral florida es un
estado crucial mientras que los
jubilados votan tradicionalmente por los
republicanos la población latina apoya a
los demócratas por lo que los resultados
siguen siendo ajustados en florida en
2016 el estado votó con un 48 6% por
donald trump